saludos en este vídeo quiero que
reduzcamos esta fórmula de aquí que es
la fórmula para la frecuencia de
pulsación recuerden que la forma en la
que encontramos pulsos o la frecuencia
de pulsación es superponiendo dos ondas
que tengan frecuencias diferentes cuando
hacemos esto obtenemos pulsos esta es
una onda de sonido que pasa de ser alta
es decir constructiva a destructiva o
suave y luego regresa a ser alta
constructiva nuevamente y el número de
oscilaciones que hace esto por segundo
es la frecuencia de pulsación y la forma
en la que encontramos esta frecuencia de
pulsación es tomar la diferencia entre
las dos frecuencias individuales de las
dos ondas de sonido que se están
superponiendo pero porque es ésta la
fórmula de la frecuencia de pulsación
porque no fue algo más complicado porque
resultó ser esto esto es lo que quiero
que reduzcamos en este vídeo y la forma
en que vamos a hacerlo es diciendo él
encontrar esto vamos a encontrar primero
esto el periodo de pulsación así que la
frecuencia de pulsación es el número de
oscilaciones por segundo y el periodo de
pulsación va a ser el número de segundos
por oscilación en otras palabras que
tanto le lleva a este proceso ir de
interferencia constructiva todo el
camino hasta ser de nuevo constructiva
ya que si podemos encontrar esto este
período de pulsación y si ya sabemos que
la frecuencia es el inverso del periodo
si encuentro el período de pulsación lo
único que tengo que hacer es encontrar
el inverso de éste para obtener su
frecuencia como obtengo esto como
encuentro el período de pulsación lo
encontramos al reconocer que este
período de pulsación es el tiempo que le
lleva para que estas ondas se desfasen
de tal forma que estos picos que
originalmente se superponían terminan
superponiéndose otra vez
más adelante en el proceso vamos a
limpiar esto y ahora analicemos ambas
ondas individualmente suponiendo que
inician en fase tendremos interferencia
perfectamente constructiva así que aquí
suponemos que inician constructivamente
y solo queremos saber cuánto tiempo les
lleva volver a ser constructivas
nuevamente y solo nos interesa saber
cuánto tiempo les lleva tener de nuevo
una interferencia constructiva
estamos buscando este tiempo y la forma
de encontrarlo es reconocer que si estas
ondas comenzaron en fase el tiempo que
le lleva a la honda roja completar todo
un periodo va a estar esta cantidad en
frente de la onda azul y en frente
quiere decir que va a ocurrir esta
cantidad de tiempo después de lo que
ocurre la cresta de la onda azul así que
estas crestas se encuentran un poquito
desfasadas en esta cantidad cuál será
esta cantidad pues es la diferencia
entre periodos de estas dos ondas por lo
que será el periodo de la onda 1
qué es la onda roja y nuestra onda azul
será la onda 2 de esta forma no
tendremos ningún número negativo por acá
ya que el periodo de la onda roja es un
poquito más grande que el de la onda
azul esto nos dice que están desfasados
en el tiempo se encuentran estos dos
picos así que si yo espero un ciclo se
van a encontrar exactamente esta
cantidad de tiempo desfasadas y si
espero dos ciclos voy a tener el doble
del desfase anterior si es pero tres
ciclos el desfase será tres veces el
desfase de la primera el desfase del
primer ciclo y esto en que nos ayuda
pues vean si queremos saber qué tan
separadas en el tiempo se encuentran
estas crestas en cualquier momento dado
simplemente voy a tomar esta diferencia
en el periodo y la voy a multiplicar por
el número de ciclos que ha tenido la
onda roja así que si la onda roja ha
pasado por tres ciclos aquí pongo un
tres y tres por esta diferencia esto es
qué tan separadas están las crestas en
el tiempo después de un ciclo están
separadas
esta cantidad de tiempo después de dos
ciclos están separadas esta cantidad
después de tres ciclos será esta
cantidad después de cuatro ciclos
tendrán esta separación y después de
cinco ciclos tendrán esta separación y
ahora se encuentran tan separadas que
esta onda roja se está trasladando con
la siguiente onda azul es decir la onda
roja
básicamente se está trasladando con esta
onda azul la onda azul ha avanzado en el
tiempo tantos ciclos que su siguiente
pico o cresta se va a superponer con
este pico o esta cresta de la onda roja
y es aquí cuando tenemos que se vuelve
constructiva de nuevo y esta es la
condición para que esto se vuelva
constructivo de nuevo el que esta onda
rojas se encuentre en este momento tan
desfasada que está desfasada todo un
periodo de la onda azul ya que ahora se
va atrás la par con
cresta azul que es la siguiente cresta
así que si yo quiero conocer el tiempo
que transcurre entre dos interferencias
constructivas sucesivas solo tengo que
conocer la distancia en el tiempo que se
separan estas dos ondas cuando esto va a
ser igual a todo un período de la
segunda onda así que cuando esto se
cumple yo sé que he esperado lo
suficiente para que aquí haya de nuevo
interferencia constructiva ya que la
onda azul va a estar exactamente
traslapadas con la onda roja pero quizá
a ustedes les preocupe que aquí no haya
un tiempo como voy a encontrar el tiempo
si es que aquí no hay una minúscula
bueno aquí tenemos constantes este
periodo de la onda azul es una constante
determinada por cualquiera que sea el
periodo de esta onda azul y el periodo
de la onda roja también es una constante
y está determinado por el tiempo que le
lleve recorrer un ciclo a esta onda roja
aquí no hay una variable t que despejar
pero como podemos
ser una tea que este número de ciclos
que ha recorrido la onda roja no tiene
que ser necesariamente un entero quizás
sea un entero quizá la onda roja ha
recorrido ciclos completos en este
ejemplo podemos contar 1 2 3 4 5 6
ciclos exactamente antes de volver a
estar en fase con la onda azul pero esto
no siempre ocurre esto ocurre así aquí
porque yo dibujé esta onda de tal manera
que coincidieran y pudieran ver ambas
ondas claramente pero quizá esto no es
un entero quizá esto ocurre después de
4.2 ciclos o 3.1 ciclos podemos tener
una forma más general de escribir esto
el número de ciclos por los que ha
pasado la onda roja y si hay una forma
más general de hacer esto piensen en
ello el número de ciclos por los que ha
pasado la onda roja va a ser igual al
tiempo que esperamos dividido entre el
periodo de esta misma onda roja
que le llamamos periodo 1 lo que tiene
sentido ya que si yo estoy esperando un
periodo completo un periodo 1 entonces
este tiempo del periodo 1 entre el
periodo 1 me va a dar un ciclo completo
que ha recorrido la onda roja si espero
dos periodos aquí arriba tendré dos por
el periodo 1 estos periodos 1 se van a
cancelar mutuamente y me va a quedar un
22 ciclos son los que ha recorrido la
onda roja así que esto me da la
oportunidad de escribir el número de
ciclos que ha recorrido la onda roja
como una función del tiempo que le lleve
a hacer esto aquí puedo escribir tiempos
de manera que no me dé esto un número
entero puedo poner aquí 4.3 segundos
cuantos ciclos ha recorrido la onda roja
en ese tiempo tomo estos 4 puntos 3
segundos y los divido entre el periodo
de esta onda que es el tiempo para
recorrer un ciclo completo y obtengo el
número de ciclos que ha recorrido la
onda 1 así que vamos a reemplazar esta
ese de aquí por el tiempo entre el
periodo 1 reescribimos nr como el tiempo
que esperamos entre el periodo de la
onda roja o el periodo 1 y ahora si lo
único que tengo que hacer es despejar mi
t minúscula ya que es la que me va a
decir el tiempo que les lleva a estas
dos ondas desfasarse de tal manera que
sea igual a un periodo completo de la
segunda onda que es nuestro
requerimiento para pasar de cuando se
encuentran en interferencia constructiva
a la siguiente interferencia
constructiva que tengan estas dos ondas
y justo esto es lo que buscábamos el
periodo de la pulsación
si aquí despejó omite minúscula emite
minúscula que es el tiempo que les lleva
a estos dos picos desfasarse de tal
manera que se complete el periodo
completo de la segunda onda va a ser
igual multiplico ambos lados porque uno
me queda t 1 x t 2
y todo esto es dividido por este término
entre paréntesis dividimos entre de 1
menos de 2 y estoy afirmando que este es
realmente el periodo de pulsación ya que
nosotros definimos esta condición en el
que van a estar separados todo el
periodo de la onda 2 comienzan en fase y
terminan en fase y este será el tiempo
entre los puntos constructivos así que
esto de aquí es el periodo de pulsación
así que mi periodo de pulsación es igual
a esto es el periodo de pulsación para
estas dos ondas y es una fórmula
bastante bonita pero recuerden que no
queríamos el periodo de pulsación
queríamos encontrar esta fórmula para la
frecuencia de pulsación y la forma en la
que encontramos una frecuencia es
calculando el inverso del periodo vamos
a limpiar esto
ahora vamos a calcular el inverso de
este periodo que va a ser igual a 1
entre lo que está en el lado derecho lo
que me da la diferencia entre los
periodos dividida entre el producto de
estos periodos ya que sólo invertir lo
que estaba en el lado derecho de esta
igualdad y ahora puedo expandir esto
tengo t 1 menos de 2 entre t 1 porteros
si lo expande esto va a ser igual a t 1
/ de 1 por t 2 menos de 2 / de 1 por t 2
y ahora ocurre algo mágico las t1 de
aquí se cancelan y en este otro término
las de 2 se cancelan también y me queda
que 1 entre el periodo de pulsación va a
ser igual a 1 entre el período de la
segunda onda menos 1 entre el periodo de
la primera onda pero vean que 1 entre el
periodo de pulsación va a ser la
frecuencia de pulsación así que uno
entre el periodo de pulsación va a ser
igual a la frecuencia de pulsación ya
que va a ser igual 1
el período de la segunda onda pues va a
ser igual a la frecuencia de esta
segunda onda y que es igual 1 entre el
periodo de la primera onda pues ya lo
sabe es igual a la frecuencia de la
primera onda y así obtenemos nuestra
fórmula de la frecuencia de pulsación
que es la fórmula que tratábamos de
encontrar esta es la fórmula que
queríamos deducir y lo hicimos y las
razones que tuvimos que esperar
justamente esta cantidad de tiempo el
periodo de pulsación para que estos
picos volvieran a estar en fase tuvimos
que esperar que los picos se desfasaron
justamente un periodo completo de la
segunda onda y ustedes me pueden decir a
ver un momento aquí necesitamos los
valores absolutos cierto pues sí aunque
tuvimos cuidado desde el principio para
encontrar la diferencia entre un periodo
más grande y un periodo más pequeño de
manera que restamos el pequeño del más
grande para asegurarnos de terminar con
un número positivo pero podemos poner
los
símbolos de valor absoluto en el caso en
el que ustedes no conozcan cuál de estas
frecuencias es más grande pero es así
como determinamos la fórmula de la
frecuencia de pulsación
en resumen pudimos encontrar y deducir
la fórmula para la frecuencia de
pulsación encontrando el tiempo que
tenemos que esperar para que estas ondas
sea desfase en un periodo completo que
es otra forma de decir cuánto tiempo
tenemos que esperar para que estas ondas
vuelvan a estar en fase